so the mission of learn to teach teach
to learn is to create a critical mass of
Boston youth who are creatively engaged
with science technology engineering art
and math the program itself is like
really meaningful like going out and
teaching kids like how to program just
the fundamentals of stem it can't be
like the other highway system with only
some people this is our hashtag making
liberation oh that's great we're at the
south end Technology Center and
Technology Center at Ted City at tent
city and it is located in a public
housing project tent city okay public
housing project South and Technology
Center at 10:10 city intensity as the
housing development open 17 years ago
opens no opened in 1997 we've had just
been doing learn to teach one in 1 for
17 years okay learn ok so learn to teach
has been going on 17 years and the Fab
Lab is just a fabrication lab inside of
the South End Technology Center that's
right that's been open a couple years as
well yes ok cool oh no that's the Fab
Lab we were the first Fab Lab
outside of the MIT Media Lab so it
opened in like 2002 2001 to 1516 years
yeah incredible yeah so so this
specifically serves underprivileged kids
and adults like an adult in the front
when you came in you saw personal and
professional empowerment program those
are folks who are formerly incarcerated
who are now living in in in recovery
houses and they come in here to get they
do computer skills job skills and I do
personal manufacturing which turns out
to be a really cool thing and a really
important part of getting them excited
about the future and that's really
important to do adults as well to help
me leave the program to help them get on
their feet get establish with new
digital literacy skills yeah that's so
crucial especially in the age of
automation that we're getting into
especially for them to become actualized
all this good stuff
so Susan Klum sac Clem sac dr. dr. Susan
dr. Susan Clem Zack we're here at the
South End Technology Center in Boston
and we are you've been running this now
for about 21 years or so this came from
a grant you set from the National
Science Foundation know that the center
itself came from a from a group of
teenagers in the neighborhood Mel lives
across the street that said we didn't
have act we don't have access to
computers or the Internet
yes so he started just up in the front
the Fab Lab came in about 2001 2002 so
this was a project of Mel and a couple
people in the area that wanted to have
access to technology for people to get
to that's right and it smells sort of
retirement project he retired from
teaching at the MIT Media at the MIT in
1997 and started this as his retirement
project he's 89 now and this is I when
we walked by him he seemed we we but
we've made a very slow contact of AI and
but an energy but he was moving along we
were moving along here but he it would
be so great to get to if he comes back
to get to just speak with him about what
really drove him with the feeling to
want to do this because this is so
important okay so then for the last
about 17 years there's been this program
learn to teach teach teach teach learn
so that when we were talking to Beckett
about this program what really resonated
with me is that it is
teaching how to fish that's what's
really important it's not just giving
fish it's teaching how to fish and then
it's having the kids teach other kids
how to fish so in the sense of
especially at a young age having
sophomores juniors seniors helping teach
freshmen how to use all these great
pieces of technology this it really
reminds me because he actually said he's
part of vex robotics and I work with
FIRST Robotics as well so it's very very
synergistic with what their curriculum
is like which is they get to assemble
and design and engineer robust and cleat
objectives on playing fields here it's
would you say it's much more freelance
there are certain curriculums and
programs that that older kids will teach
younger kids about how to get started
but it's also very freelance you get a
pick and be creative and do what you
want that's right we also start from the
bottom up I mean they learn how to
design the parts you know in vex
robotics which is great it gets so many
kids into things I really and in the
FIRST Robotics of our sister program so
it's a FIRST Robotics team and so it's
very very good however they don't start
programming from an Arduino and they
don't build the pieces of the robot that
they do so I'll give you one example
I'll give you one example I don't have
it working now but this is an example of
our robotics the young people build
projects every year that solve a
community issue they think important and
so this is an emotional it's not yeah
it's not going to get plugged in but if
this is an emotional robot they said
that young people don't have enough
affirmation in their lives and they
don't know how to always have people to
turn to to deal with emotions so what
they did is each of these four buttons
represents an emotion and Cameron lights
up and moves her arms when you walk her
in and when you press the button the it
asks you what you're feeling and these
are like happy sad angry
we plug it in oh I don't think I think
yeah because I think they dropped it one
day when they did it but anyway on here
when you press the button it gives you
an affirmation yeah I'm not sure if it's
going to work but it will give you an
affirmation of about that emotion and so
this is also kind of going into the
space of emotional intelligence for
artificial intelligences and this is
really important because the
non-judgmental and the empathetic
sympathetic compassionate side of humans
is sometimes missing from causation and
if there can be fully especially for
children to be able to come in exactly
that's exactly it but what I wanted to
show you is in FIRST Robotics they have
all these pieces you can see that my
young people designed and 3d printed the
whole P thing yeah the whole piece for
it and then inserted the electronics so
the focus that we have is on how young
people computers and microcontrollers
and robots as materials how can they
enhance people's lives not just giving
young people the skills to make them but
really having them think deeply about
how they can be a material that enhances
their lives yeah so it's not just about
putting the tools on the toolkit but
it's also about adding some sort of a
layer of philosophy or ethics that's
bringing value to the planet it's all of
that we call it making liberation if you
go over there if you go over here you
can see that this is this is sort of our
symbol making liberation this is our
hashtag making liberation oh that's
great so it came from a project that we
did after after Ferguson to go beyond
black lives matters towards making
liberation and using using technology
for young people to be able to express
their feelings
what they think they deserve and we
actually got a grant from the Harvard
Graduate School of Education Equity Fund
and they they went through a process
where they used hip-hop pedagogy they
they did they exploit spoken word they
felt it I can word how they how they
felt in graffiti fact the graffitis up
over here I can share come on with me is
up there that they did and then they
developed and then they developed
projects that expressed their there
towards making liberation yeah expressed
what they thought youth deserve they
came up with the youth manifesto and
they developed these projects and then
they did a they did a workshop for
graduate students and professors at the
Harvard Graduate School of Education on
this so ever since then that's been a
real theme for for us and and at the
Tech Center it evolves and I love how
you're incorporating art yes into the
digital literacy as well and so that you
were showing us this a little bit
earlier but I love the organization here
he's so organized all of the different
pieces that are needed to assemble
whatever they want to build and there's
also images for the visual as well this
is just very well well done and if you
open up you know what did I open up
earlier I opened up in Arduino Nano
that's what I opened up and and so at
any point kids can decide hey I want to
follow something on YouTube or I want to
go and piece something together that
just sporadically is coming to my mind
and I want to play around with it and
see what I can do with it you provide
that safe space the mentorship you
provide all the different tools that are
needed
what would you say out of the out of the
kids that come in here what is the
average age of the kid
what yeah what approximate year are they
in school so we have we have in the door
to teach teach to learn program we hire
each year 36 teenagers who represent
Boston in 17 years I've always had half
young men half young women never had a
problem don't understand what all this
stuff is because it's very easy and in
fact all my college mentors this year
are young women who are now studying who
were in the program and are now studying
computer science amazing and engineering
mechanical and electrical good Wow and
and let's see computer engineering
computer science mechanical engineering
and and electrical engineering right now
and so every year 36 every year 36 and
they represent all the cultural groups
in Boston they represent for all the
schools 14 to 18 and 19 if they're still
in school okay
the ones that teach are more the 18 17
year olds all 36 all 36 teach so there's
there's a there's a it's a multiple
layer role model system so we have
college mentors now that were 17 years
going who come back after they've gone
to college they were former youth
teachers and they helped to train the
young people the the 30 16 836 teenagers
within those about a third to a half of
the young people come back every year
the youth teachers the teens come back
every year it's good so we have a you
know Gabe over there who's doing his
internship with me has been with us for
four years yeah so then in the summer
time after they train in April through
to 3rd June at here and at the MIT Media
Lab which is where you saw them yeah and
and then in July and July in August they
are here 25 hours a week the first three
weeks they design and build a project
that uses a
these three technologies they've learned
and then that gives some confidence
competence and then they go out the last
three to four weeks of the program and
they travel to last year it was 25
community organizations carrying three
to four weeks worth of equipment so that
they can do hands-on learning and they
reach 700 elementary and middle school
kids at 25 community organizations all
located in the areas of Boston most in
need of Education resources so we had
like 14 there you see if I can cover
this in paraphrase again so we're at 36
all the teenagers are now going to teach
with this mobile equipment they built up
this confidence in this courage and the
skill sets they need to go out into the
community to twenty five different
community organizations that are then
impacting 600-700 elementary to middle
school exactly and they do that how how
often it's a three to four week free
summer seeing kids it's a summer steam
camp
yeah they offer it so they go out you
know every day or every other day to
these organizations and teach different
sometimes more than one group of kids
they'll have a couple of sessions so and
the community organizations I think it
was last year I did it
87 percent of the community
organizations would not have any stem
enrichment if it weren't for us yeah
because we do it free so we have we have
go to community we go to housing
developments I have you can have to give
you have to give Gabe a hug too because
he's one of my he's one of my youth
teachers yes he'll tell you a lot about
the program and what he's gotten out of
it hey Gabe we're coming over to you for
coming over to you yeah and I'll stand
next to him so he can get on my mic that
works you gave are you okay with
chatting a little bit okay all right
I'll just stand near you so if we get
your mind
nobody so why don't you been here four
years now right yeah okay and so you're
part of the group of the 36 that have
learned the skills that you need to go
and impact kids in the community
elementary middle school kids how do you
feel about this what are your thoughts
about it
well like the program itself is like
really meaningful like going out and
teaching kids like how to program just
the fundamentals of stem especially when
like sometimes they go into the program
and like they're not very interested in
science at all and then like after us a
couple sessions with them like you'll
see them really start to get it and
really start to like getting like
excited about science so like just that
part of it isn't really really
meaningful so that yeah that feeling of
first introducing the subject and
getting a little bit of hesitation or
uncomfortability or the lack of
confidence like I don't know that I
don't it's a foreign to me it's strange
to me and then how do you how do you
introduce it to them in a way that's fun
that gets them excited about it yeah
well like really we start introducing
them to scratch so like scratch is just
about scratching right so scratches of
like programming language that's
supposed to be like an introduction to
coding and so like you can make
animations you can make games with
scratch really you've like you can make
anything um this is based in like block
coding so like it's something created by
MIT and so like you stock blocks on top
of each other and there's a sequence of
code that rock exactly so it runs top to
bottom who also like you can make loops
and everything so it's just getting like
the logic of computer science in their
computational thinking yes okay and so
so then once what what is this usual
like first activity that they do using
scratch what is what are some of the
first
well sometimes we'll jump right into it
but it's usually just an introduction to
like how to make a sprite so a sprite
will write BNE like a character in a
story or like a character in a game and
then we start teaching them how to make
that character move and so something
that's interesting about scratch is that
it uses a like the Cartesian plane so
that's like the x and y coordinates yeah
and sometimes depending on how young the
kids are like they won't exactly like
have learned that in math yeah yeah yeah
and so sometimes like what we do you can
almost leapfrog them in today anyway
exactly yeah and so like sometimes we'll
introduce them to that if they're too
young there's also like you can make
your character move steps and so that
sometimes it's easier to understand so
they make them move to the left or to
the right you're making point up or down
depending on where you wanted to move
but yeah that's the introduction we have
what's one of the activities that you
think that the children they the youth
teachers taught with scratch that the
children really enjoy yeah oh there was
one where I forgot what it was called
those like the characters would fly
around and they'd have like trails
behind them oh yes yeah yeah yeah and
there's like why exactly yeah yeah like
that was something that the kids like
really loved because they could make
their own characters make them fly
around control them and so like
especially when you give kids like the
reins and designing the character and
designing like what their environment is
like you see them really really get
excited about the stuff that they're
learning yeah yeah this oh man we were
talking about the importance of the
child's realization that they have this
potential that you've added a tool to
their tool belt and then they get to be
creative with it and then they realize
that maybe I want to pursue this and I
want to build in it or I want to teach
it to other people along the way as well
it seems like a very important
especially in an underprivileged area
aspect of culture to develop so
so 54 years so now you're 17 yeah well
I'm 18 recently turned okay yeah and so
now after four years of this program now
like and you're teaching it now and
you've learned it now what do you want
to do where are you going oh I'm going
to Princeton yeah awesome what do you
what do you want to study well I'm
thinking of studying like computer
science or electrical engineering I'm
still like deciding on the two awesome
yeah congratulations thank you and so
then do you know as you like studying do
you kind of know if you want to continue
doing something in building your making
or what do you think right yeah yeah so
I really like the aspect of like
building and creating things like with
your own hands yeah so yeah that's
definitely something I want to have like
in my career are you building anything
right now
so I've made a soldering mistake so I'd
have to solder this but um this is like
a shield for the Arduino so the Arduino
is like a microcontroller it's not like
a little computer that you can code and
so and can you get that for like 10 or
20 bucks from Shenzhen is that fairly
this is I I don't buy them I buy them
for about $20 from Sparkfun
okay because that's I want I want
they're they're really quality there's
some things that you want to invest it
to have better quality yeah yeah yeah
the $20 that's that's a very affordable
price yeah okay great
so and then how do you how do you begin
to program this and you need to connect
it to your computer right yes so micro
USB connection or Ethernet yeah this is
micro USB mini this is the mini G this
is a B this is a regular B there's a
baby pea in my pool and so then once
you're plugged in what software are you
using to programs are
so there's yeah let's show us yeah well
just application called the Arduino IDE
the Arduino I D yeah so random like so
ide ide yes
so that's hey okay cool cool and so yeah
this is all line coding yep yep so
scratch and the micro bit with it yeah
does that dog long Tony yeah yeah so
that that would be more like of course
you have for tonight open yeah that
would be more like this uh-huh
yeah that's there's your basic block
coding huh but the IDE and line coding
is like that yeah yeah but go back to
the block coding for us quick yep so
this is what you're getting like v like
fifth-graders on right so that yeah this
would be fifth graders mostly elementary
school kids and so this is something
that we just introduced to the program
so this is like interesting this is a
Microsoft program yes yes so that this
entire thing is developed by Microsoft
and so you can have here like you can do
line coding on this so they have like
two alternatives so you can have line
coding or you can just make it blocks
but it's easier to visualize with the
blocks especially if you're just
starting on this but essentially you can
have like so that this is like a
simulation of our show LEDs yeah and so
you can like make any design and so then
so then then just like that or forever
you can get to do it on start or forever
and that show that and then as time goes
you can change it to do other exactly
your timeline oh yeah you like you can
start adding logic to it so you're
saying so your x axis is time and your
y-axis is items well so the thing about
these is that each Susan went back to
work he's like okay I gave I gave him
over to Gabe for a bit
so with these it's like each of these uh
I'm not exactly sure what to call them
but what many sets got a blah highlight
it over again highlight over again it's
a small step in showing you the
functionality of it exactly yeah that's
the other thing when a button a beat or
both a B is pushed down and released
again right okay so that's that's saying
that whether you have a pressed or be
pressed or both a and B press right and
so you can change that here so look we'd
say when button a pressed we make like a
plus sign right you know yeah yeah so
right now forever we're showing this
area would make more sense to do it on
star yeah
so I'll start we show this then when but
a press it changes here exactly and that
this is a this is a micro bit which is
exactly what you know you know a Beckett
Dunning yes yeah yeah yeah yeah we just
talked to him yesterday really yeah it's
a two days ago my gosh time time flies
two days ago and he was showing us a
micro bit so that's so now you're you're
showing us the block programming which
was working with the micro bit and then
the line coding is what you're using for
the Arduino yes and then the line coding
on the Arduino you're writing up a
program and what exactly are you writing
up on that program so what are you
trying to do with this so right now like
it's the early stages so I'm just
testing that it works a lot of it is
just saying like when this button is
pressed play like a specific note on the
speaker got it got it
and then like eventually you might be
able to say like control like the scale
that it's on or whatever is and then
even here like this is a three toggle
switch so you have like different modes
so it not just on or off on off since
yeah cool so
a programmable guitar exactly yeah nice
nice so then when do kids usually start
picking this up start playing with this
so this is actually something we haven't
introduced to the program this is just
something that Susan wanted me to work
on this is exciting yeah yeah they get
to play with two two birds in one stone
they get computer science and they get
music I like stone I've always thought
that same thing is we don't like the
aggressive ones to wait two eggs one
bird yeah they hatch two birds with one
egg so we have like we have a two birds
one egg here because we have them
computer science and music at the same
time that's great and that's how they
really make really strong
interdisciplinary connections between
music and art and science and it was
combined so this is a neat I'm excited
for this to be added to the program what
else yeah what else what else can you
can you show us I mean yeah there's a
lot here another thing we should I'm
just seeing this this is a makey makey
and so the way I'm making make it works
uh-huh so when you connect it to the
computer
whenever you complete a circuit let's
see if I need it Susan will come back
with you after this okay okay we have
with some more thoughts to run by you
so let's yeah okay let's plug it in huh
there so whenever you complete the
circuit it'll act as if you did
something on your computer so for
example these two tabs when you connect
them to ground mm-hmm so it's because my
hand is conductive so right now this is
grounded now so this right here is
ground and so it'll act like I hit the
left button on my keyboard
aha so we have a couple of examples here
let's see if I can no internet
connection
interesting so scratch was made about 20
years ago by MIT or time you know
congratulations
such a good idea let's see this might be
a good one dragon game yeah so this is a
game I made so you made this yes yeah
yeah
so this was just as actually had the
program the colors of the pixels and
everything yeah so the I can actually
take you inside the program so really it
all looks like this interesting that's
this is that's all that's going on right
now so know that this is just for this
right oh that's only for the Dragon roll
wow so this is quite complicated so this
would be to control the the actual
player
this is providing which costume to
costume five and then wait two seconds
switch costume costume three wait two
seconds is that way the dragon is
constantly changing it's exhausting
and so in here this is the player so
yeah you'll see that like eventually as
he gets closer to the dragon he'll like
change the way he's moving and so that
those are all costumes and so this year
you have different costumes for the
Dragon as well but essentially yeah this
was meant as a sort of introductions who
they explode the controller so that
that's usually makeymakey in and got it
got it
we don't have any buttons here but
essentially you can like play the game
just by going like this yeah yeah but uh
you can also hook these up to like
jumper cables like alligator clips and
play with buttons like in the real world
these instructions are so interesting
when clicked switch costume to pick a
random one to to go to front go to back
three layers set pixelate effect 225 so
then you have a certain pixelation
effect so that's how to keep it either
pixelated or not right
yeah a pixelated so I wanted the feel
of like an arcade game or just like so
higher pixelation is our higher effect
number is more pixelation right so if
you set pixelated effect to 50 and you
look at the dragon you'll see that he
got some much more much more pixelated
yeah but he said it to one if you set it
to one that's like almost nothing at all
yeah exactly
it looks very crisp yeah right and so 24
25 is just like the number I decided on
yeah yeah cool
nice so then you have the dragon where
can you show us the algorithm for the
dragon the warning in the fire right so
for the warning it's this is really just
quite simple so it's whenever yeah
whatever the dragon says like oh I'm
about to throw a fireball you just flash
it and then you hide it otherwise like
otherwise they'll be hidden it's hidden
yeah and then it repeats every 3 seconds
so it that it repeats three times
whenever it receives a message from the
dragon and the message shows up every
couple of right the message shows up
whenever the dragon decides that like
let's see if I show you here so so here
the the dragon is going to like writing
this Ross yeah okay that's random right
yeah so the dragon X is a position so
it's just gliding over to a random
position like every like second or so it
takes a while for it to get there so I
have to ask so I see that there's
different colors so purple is for looks
right yeah that's the color
yeah so it'll be color it'll be like the
effects on it so it's so your pixelation
was one exactly yeah uh-huh and then so
the control is yellow and then the dark
blue is motion right okay cool yes so
that's it's pretty well explained and
well compartmentalized in a way that
makes sense
there's all these little sprites like
you said so then the essence is to use
use you scratch to make sprites exactly
yeah okay so the way these sprites
interact is all to you you know like
yeah that that's essentially how games
are made and awesome and then this right
here is just like the backgrounds so the
backgrounds isn't a sprite itself it's
its own like a separate thing yeah so
okay before we go back to Susan why
don't you give us a quick tell us a
little bit more about this feeling of
once the kids like actually playing with
it and they're getting it and they're
like whoa this is so neat like what do
you tell us about that feeling what is
that like yeah so like I remember
there's one time I had to go teach and
so we went to this Community Center in
Boston and there was one kid in
particular who just didn't want to code
at all right so like coding just sounded
like something for nerds or something
like he didn't want to do and so he had
kind of just decided that he wasn't
gonna listen to us and so I remember
like going over and like asking the
class like hey like how our video games
made right it's like what video games do
you play
he was like Mario Kart I play like then
now would be fortnight but like it was
Mario Kart oh yeah stuff like that and
so I was like well someone had to sit
down and code that game right those
games were made by people sitting down
programming and so when I told him that
they he started getting interested like
he was interested and so he started
thinking like Oh could I design like my
own Minecraft game could I design
something like Mario Kart could I do
something like that and so like that the
class was kind of derailed but like
everyone was so much more interested in
what we were teaching because of it so
we decided to start making this
relatable example exact of the kids like
video games but there had to be a whole
team of people that work together to
make this game for them okay and then
they were like okay aha that makes sense
so now this is what is starting to
interest me a little
he managers so what did that yeah
continue with that story how'd that go
so that this it went really really well
they decided to like make their games so
they gave it a try
yeah no yeah they started making games
so right so they really just needed
interesting they needed to know that the
game did not just come from magic from a
black box they needed to know that it
was actually created designed and
engineered by other people and that they
themselves could do that too right
because it's interesting because now
it's so easy to download the game on
your phone and you have no idea where it
came from
yes like you have no idea like the
months of effort it took from a group of
programmers to put on your phone and so
like really with with scratch in
particular kids are starting to see the
develop on the side of the game yeah and
that that's what makes everything so
much more interesting especially because
they have everything like so intuitive
like like you were talking about the
color coding and everything so great
brights are so great yeah it's something
that a kid can really interact with and
that's why scratch is really great and
that's why we're going out and teaching
it I love it I love it I'm sure
MIT loves you guys for doing and
teaching so many people scratch as well
there are millions of kids all over the
world
you shared show um the scratch site oh
yes yeah so so um so there's a million
people using scratch across the world is
that every year every day or do we know
tell you so yeah oh and then they all up
so it's all open source of them they're
all uploading their code like what the
games they made and then people are
playing that they remix the game what's
what people in the community are loving
and what their remix see come look at
this as a parkour boy yeah this is a
project that's someone made and it's
featured so it's a featured right now
yeah and so it's just doing parkour
hardcore yeah jumping from there
and it's reiax oh you can't touch the
red okay yeah that's the that's the and
interesting oh and it looks like there's
looks like either Mandarin or or
Japanese a Korean over there that's
what's interesting about scratch
everybody yeah interesting and so people
leave comments they remix these games
can you pull the code right now to look
at yeah I bet this is a little bit more
complicated oh cool cool I see how its
built-in there's like a lot of cake did
yeah yours right there yeah cool but
yeah this is awesome oh there's only
like three four sprites really it's such
a limited sprite game - yeah I thought
it's the yeah here it is he really just
plays with the background so that is you
can change the background or whatever
one yeah so okay that's this is this is
so cool it's a this is basically the
engineering social platform for kids
that's exactly a coding social platform
that's so interesting that was this was
solid Gabe so it's great I'm happy that
we got to meet each other as well yeah
yeah I miss me it was super fun let's
give this give me hey so good to meet
you um and thanks for doing this four
years at it and hiring people and then
also about to go to uh piston and crush
it there there's a job there and build
the future I think so we can look at the
way look at the way that he's teaching
and he's talking about it so fluidly you
know you think yeah you're welcome
you're welcome
alright let's get let's get let's pass
the mic back over to Susan you give back
at doing the guitar I'm still obsessed
with the fact they're combining
engineering with music that's a really
thank you I really really wanted to go
to Tufts about weeding good to go oh
well I can hook you up I do I do I do
I've been doing this for 17 years I know
everybody and I work with milking it was
really great to engage with Gabe mm-hmm
because that's first-hand experience
yeah that was really beautiful
yes yeah Oh Gabe is very beautiful my
energy is he's a Greek he's got great
social skills as well you know your
personal skills are really important to
develop as well
technologies of the heart yeah
technologies of the heart in fact can I
come over here and show you something
that spring although we have you won't
be able to see the whole thing because
somebody moved the this organ over here
and I don't know who I'm gonna find a
few um oh sweet
so Beijing urban youth to catalyze
cultural change in their community that
is the best week so the mission of learn
to teach teach to learn is to create a
critical mass of Boston youth who are
creatively engaged with science
technology engineering art and math yes
uh who can catalyze cultural change in
their communities about what's possible
to do with technology so this is awesome
self-efficacy collective efficacy yes
self-efficacy collective efficacy that's
right and then the collective's teaching
the individuals the individuals they're
learning themselves they're able to
provide again so cool yes so
technologies this is what you're looking
at here is a research poster I think we
are the only group that applied for an
AE RA grant I don't notice no American
Education Research Association
it's the biggest Education Research
Association and
the world and we applied to have do
what's called a participatory research
that means that the young people and
college mentors served as researchers as
well as participants you know and who we
were looking at in the study so that is
very very unique so you can see I worked
with my friend Jay enjou from University
of Connecticut and then these are these
are the college mentors and youth
teachers on the research and Beckett was
one of Alex
I do love Julia Elias and Amelia and so
and so then this is this is the group
that you did this research with I see a
Mel King quote here if we want a society
and culture that works for everyone we
need innovation in our relationships
along with innovation in the STEM fields
and in STEM education yeah exactly that
works for everyone yeah so so what they
did is they did a year-long research
project and they looked at what do you
need besides skills to get young people
of color living with low incomes in
urban areas who into not only into stem
but really dedicated to it and going on
to study it in college yeah so um they
came up with a purpose and they came up
with their methods and data sources may
came up with their research questions
and one of the things that they came up
with is that you need not only
technologies of the earth the hard core
thing you need technologies of the heart
and those are those that ago G of love
and change there you go there you go and
so technologies of the heart are what
they really came up with and that that
is those technologies that are necessary
to bring out the best in us what are
they tell us about with each other and
with in our
communities well they are let's see they
are they they are developing positive
relationships to failure yeah catalyzing
cultural change in their communities
there's sort of a culture of near peer
learning so you can help each other it's
a learning philosophy where you're not
you're you we always we have two core
questions that we ask after every learn
to teach session whether it's with the
children or with the youth teachers we
ask what did you learn and then we ask
what did you what can you teach someone
else else because teaching someone else
you should never learn just for yourself
once you learn something you have an
obligation to share it with others
yeah we have an obligation to enrich
humanity we were birthed in this world
let's give back to it so you bring up
this so they did Europe ear learning we
learn that from Beckett yes or two days
ago
yes near pure learning this is important
because we learning from somebody like
me that's like twenty five teaching a 12
year old is a different feeling than
when it's a 14 year old teaching the 12
year old because the 12 year old can
then be like hey that person is like
near my age there they look like me
they look like me they all in two years
I'll be teaching as well so there's a
closed loop there that's soaked I've
never actually put those words together
near peer that's why that's so well we
have they've been trying to get enough
role models within Boston public schools
teachers who look like the young people
that they serve 85 percent of young
people in the Boston Public School
System are young people of color and 5%
yes and it's something like 20 15
percent of the teachers right and it
gets even smaller when you go into
science technology engineering and math
so there are no role models so
we that we couldn't we couldn't and
there's this achievement gap so it's
even 17 years ago we say we couldn't
wait for the slow pace of school reform
in Boston Public Schools we have to do
something now and we had to we had we
felt that the young people could be
filling in this gap of teacher role
models right right you know because
they're not getting them and it and
research shows is so important to have
these role models plus the children
always want to be doing what the cool
teenagers are doing right so they they
just to be and the cool teenagers always
ignore the elementary and middle school
kids they don't want to hang out with
them so when you put those two together
that's like you know that's a wonderful
recipe because the kids wanna you know
imitate they already want to imitate
those teenagers really community that's
right oh and there's this pipeline like
for instance this year I have six youth
teachers who were in our summer steam
camps when they were elementary school
and middle school and they decided that
when they became 14 they wanted to come
to learn to teach teach to learn to be a
youth teacher and be cool like our
teenagers are right and then we have
young people who who see our college
mentors who were former youth teachers
and say if they can do that I can do
that too right yep so so it's very cool
I love it in the in the model is very
unique and so I was was it Beckett
teaching me that you are going to other
places as well now you're trying to take
the model and tell their place yes we've
taken into some schools we've seeded the
model in to Boston Public Schools under
the radar and now they want to put it in
the exam schools but we seated in the
McKinley South End Academy which serves
young people who have experienced trauma
whether it's gun violence foster care
system abuse whatever and they have
learning disabilities so they can't be
mainstreamed
and we knew that this would benefit the
youth so we brought a group of teachers
and students over here one year and
trained in here and under the radar we
raise the money to install a Fab Lab in
there and there are young people there
who will come to school just because
they'll have Fab Lab that day yeah right
so it's very cool and we're doing the
same thing at the Madison Park technical
and vocational high school and this year
we're starting a program there that
smells put together the next phase of
Babla yeah the next phase of fab labs is
machines making machines you can
actually fabricate machines for two you
can fabricate 3d printers you can
fabricate three CNC routers in fab labs
so we're having a program at the
technical and vocational high school
this summer where where young people
teens and their teachers will learn this
together and actually make 3d printers
and various things with our classrooms
so it's very cool we have one back there
that was made in the Fab Lab which is
very very very cool a little 3d printer
and it's actually fancier than any of
the 3d printers we have so we've done
that so can I tell you the third thing
yeah we're also international last year
you saw that vendor Ino that was given
to me by David Kirk rotelli's who's was
what part of the original Arduino team
who designed it and he teased me because
there was a conference there and they
actually called it learn to teach teach
to learn because I guess like you a
group of folks came in here and they
happened to be from Spanish fab labs and
they wanted to develop a program for
Syrian Revolution and northern African
refugees they were kids who've been
orphaned they're between 16 and 22 they
need something a community to hold them
and a path forward so they started a
program called the breakers program
modeled after learn to teach teach to
learn that I didn't even know about
until last July or August when I
everything was crazy here in these
will you come and Keynote our conference
in Spain I didn't even have a passport
because I've been so yeah I would learn
to teach teach and they said we want you
to keynote a conference because we've
had two years of success eight fablabs
all these young people we are using your
model come and help us take it to the
next level so I was the keynote I got my
passport and ran and did everything and
I went out there and I spent about ten
days in Madrid and in Barcelona yeah and
I did I did some activities with them I
keynoted this conference David was the
second keynote and he's not used to be
he teased me but he designed this fender
Eno and gave it to me so when Gabe said
he wanted to do his internship here for
his senior year at Roxbury Latin school
I said why don't you build a fender Eno
for me we can use it to inspire other
youth come on in Mel I know
so you that's where you experienced that
so we're international you are
international now you're extending into
a couple of schools in Boston yeah and I
love how you said them machines making
machines now that's it this is your guy
to talk about machines maybe with you
watching this TV program it whether it
had these kids are geniuses yeah they
could spell and come back with your head
up yeah you're like I was amazed yeah
and that's what I was very good but I
wouldn't even mention it's right
because minds are just able to do the
crazy stuffs my young Wow
I know I've seen some of the programming
I've just been blown away by what
they're yeah that's why exposing them to
this when they're young is really about
that as a basis for where they come out
in their future you're helping build
that foundation so what was it 21 years
ago that you had the realization that
you wanted to provide the community with
something like this well the way to tell
the story is said they were calling this
thing information highway yeah and
having some understanding of what the
National Defense highways and all the
highways that went from north to south
east to west in the country but the one
thing we noticed about it was that some
people could get on cuz it went back to
them but other people had to go 10 miles
or whatever I wanted to get on yeah and
so working at MIT and hearing them talk
about the information highway yes so
wait a minute it can't be like the other
highway system with only some people can
get on yeah and so in the information
highways a very important highways
listen you know a lot of our lives are
wrapped around information and so I said
wait a minute
can't let that be that do a lot of folks
will not be able to get access so I
organized a national conference on the
information Highway and I'll show you
the a book report of it and because I
said this is 20 years ago yeah in 94 Wow
and I'm MIT technology know about its
power and its potential and so when I
retired I said one office on the campus
I want some money so we can open up
Senate because young people around were
talking about these internet cafes and
so and talking to some of them on the
corners they would say we are mighty yes
I just but I want to try and put
something together and that's what they
wanted to see happen it's part of what I
was talking about and so I got and I
opened up this other side was very very
important and we did first was to get
people to fix computers we've got some
of the old computers places with all the
way put them in and people learn
they do that nine of the first 30 folks
they were in college and these are the
computer for it and so they came they
learned etc and it was really a pivotal
point in that we yes good computers got
the place open and it was being used to
an extent that these women that it we're
using the computers and then using them
for their studies okay yeah well if they
fix pool take kept one that's great yeah
I mean that was the process for anybody
I was the women and I think six of them
were residents in this complex so okay
now right so we opened up we're moving
in that direction and then we just opens
a little waiter Oh summer comes right
and so we stay open later people come
with their children etc so that they
could themselves take advantage but
because weights games and things they
take the plate with the computers I was
fine and then I realized as one day I
was looking though and I don't know if
you're even neighborhood just caught you
school it was cool that was a program of
based on the what they call the war on
[Music]
poverty
set up after school and summer jobs or
and so looking out and see the kids and
they did other dogs but they were
sweeping the street you know cleaning
the parks and stuff and I said wait a
minute and I recall what I did in the
60s I got some girls few boys to learn
to teach reading and writing to children
work with Northeastern University and we
put this together and they would they
work with some of the children and then
we did this other thing with one of the
schools and had our youth teaching peer
equations and when they compared the
scores all the kids that were exposed to
these young people with the request of
young people and they work the kids work
they'll have two sometimes three grades
ahead of what they would have been if it
was just in the regular classroom so as
I was looking out and saw what some of
the young wait a minute and I remember
back to the sixties and I said forget
some of the youth to learn how to do the
technology but so they could teach you
to younger kids okay and so the good
thing about that because we could hook
up with the neighborhood youth core
funds and we could find a way to pay to
you and so we set it up and we
eventually came to what we call learn to
teach teach to learn which is what you
just learned about from from Susan and
it was that model that's good
you've been going up and teaching and
well you know the rest of the sword
you're so passionate about the
information highways you wanted to pave
an information highway in an area of
underserved community well yes it was
one everybody's good access yeah you
know cuz young people left out that's a
model and I think is what's important is
that you can get to learn and teach and
movies you know more than most of the
teachers in the schools about certain
aspects of the technology and so they
have ability to get out and do that is
very very important not only for the
other youth their teaching but for what
they're learning about themselves you
things to take them they can accomplish
helps them with retaining the
information but it also helps them deal
with interpersonal skills because every
child learns differently from other
children she having the capacity to
share that knowledge with others and to
work in ways to help to use what they
think
and so I've operated on this role model
approach it works if you were to
interview some of the youth you'll see
that they were the program
and didn't we talk to Gabe we talked to
Gabe right here too and Beckett but we
when we talked to to Gabe especially
he's been with four years now in the
program about he's going and teaching
other young kids and we're talking about
exactly what what when he when he brings
scratch into the hands of the young kids
and they they get it and even if they
weren't ready to get it at first they
were rebellious but then they was told
that you know the video game that you
play on your phone well it took six
months for a team of people to build it
just like you could do right now and
they ran so then they get used to it and
they play it and and then their minds
are expanded to these new dimensions of
thinking and game was really interesting
because he had built up these and her
personal skills he'd build up these
coding skills and now he's going to
Princeton and you know this is really a
this is like you said it's a building an
information Highway in an area that was
lacking one and then it's stimulating
that part of town with this information
highway well last night watched a TV oh
Jesus yeah young people who well they
could spell sentences backwards they
could do all things with math and and my
marble and what they're able to do and
then they put on a clip about systems of
the body and they showed something and
they asked you to name the pot and what
it did Wow and I've sat there and I
chuckled why cuz one of the programs
that we developed here
about systems of the body I think I'm
upstairs
we just leased PhD has a lot of
knowledge about the body and systems and
I said can you come and because I think
you can get to use to make games about
the systems of the body and they could
teach him little brothers sisters and
others about the body and so anyhow I
should get a clip in and show you I she
came down she did the rough overview of
it and then we got the young people to
learn about the systems of the body and
then develop again about one of the
systems we started with the dietary
system and they did things they went out
in the street or to places with people
purchasing food trucks and why they
bought such and such and then I'm about
you know what they understood about the
diet that comes from reaching certain
foods and so what they did was they came
back we used to scratch program
developed at MIT I took him over to MIT
so that they could understand more about
it and then they started making games
for others about the dietary system
awesome and so they
I don't maybe he's that a clip I show
that we could get for you to see a
little piece of what happened it wasn't
with the sprite so that the sprite would
be the character that might digest
another sprite in the mouth
well you know there was a piece of the
body that they showed and said such and
such what does it mean I have to have to
ask you a couple of their thoughts
because I want to we've we've been
recording a long time for this episode
and we want to you want to make it so
that it's still digestible for people
that are watching at home on a couple
really assistants of the body and the
first one was so the question is why
these information highways across
underprivileged areas and what they do
anything uplifting those areas and
maximizing the impact of those groups of
people what do you think we can do to
work together collectively to make more
information superhighways well I think
you if you see something that works
sharing spreading yeah this is what I
think you're doing I think this is very
very important to tell you about going
out to California
which is providing them people come with
an opportunity to learn from each other
those kinds of things that they've been
successful with now I don't know if you
looked at the big poster
poster poster yeah okay well so you're
saying take the stuff that works with
making these information superhighways
and replicate it across and make them
better but but and go to other countries
in the world where there are favelas or
shanty towns in these places that have
underprivileged areas and bring the
information highways there absolutely
but actually I think under privilege I
look at it in that way the question is
access access access that they can get
them to to that but also for them to
understand kind of power that they now
have that they can distribute to others
in a way that you can work with them you
know that what you're doing is making a
difference yeah and that you run into
people and I don't know if she told you
about these 13 year old Lucy twins who
after watching and participating with
the high school and college mentis said
to the director of the program we want
to teach the five and six and eight year
olds in the way that we were taught etc
yeah so they set it up you should ask
her to tell you about it and these 13 14
year olds us cut out kids and taught the
six seven year old young what they had
learned using some of the same I have to
tell you when I heard and saw that I
smiled because it was the approach that
we wanted worked well that's its
approach that's worked you you you you
named it this way you said areas in the
world that have low access these tools
that help children with their creativity
with their innovation with learning 21st
century skills with those areas that
have that low access you know how to now
build a superhighway for that
information to get to that area and to
stimulate the youth there as well as the
the economies in that area and have
those ideas come to life tell you a mode
that polska yeah we went into depth
about the post okay that's that yeah
that's crucial that's that's the recipe
that's the information that's don't need
to say anything else
no how about one question for you before
we call it we asked this question on our
show a lot what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
well love my porch ebooks love is the
question and the answer and the power of
love when open source
I sucked me somebody will hear about
that concept and said you know and I
have a poem called it's about the power
of love and key aspect of it is that it
opens doors and one of the things that I
learned in talking to native folks about
the difference between the culture that
they came up with is and I have it in
the poem so love of power builds fences
the power of love opens doors yeah and
that to me a framework for community
building communities about and getting
people to understand the importance of
sharing and caring and I learned that I
know maybe 15 16 years ago and one of my
we're closed and in the West where in
talking to some folks and one of the
tribe they describe the difference
between
opposed but they were involved in
culturally and what the Europeans and
others were involved in and it's
definitely yeah a little that when you
to have things go on the whole cultural
change you're describing cultures that
have they prioritize the power of love
instead of the love of power the love of
power is gonna build fences but the
power of love is gonna open doors we
talked about on the show all the time
you're doing that here right now and
you're creating areas of low have your
identifying areas of low access you're
building these information highways
there and this has been an incredible
time here Mel thank you for putting all
this together and working with this team
inspiring these kids yeah my students at
MIT when talking about things we do she
said teamwork makes the dream work
yeah all right so not me we had a team
and we had a dream better was a team
that takes teamwork yes and we can't get
anything else out there I want people to
understand that yes see how was that an
event we had stopped the highway from
coming through and one of the things
that was an outgrowth of it was
the fact that we build community gardens
and there's a Southwest closer to God
yeah and we had a time what happened and
people were saying you did I said wait a
minute and I asked him to repeat after
me
teamwork makes the dream work teamwork
makes the dream and that's only way I
know how to work function teamwork and
it's so applicable to globalization and
what's going on across the world is
putting up these massive fences and
these massive borders is not working
together as a team and when we open up
to the power of love we will open up
these doors to teamwork and making this
dream work and again you're doing that
your first hand Mel thank you thank you
thank you thank you that's my middle
name thank you so much I really
appreciate you let me did you this has
been an incredible episode here we
greatly appreciate everyone for tuning
in if there is if there are some
takeaways it's that that the love for
power is gonna put up all these fences
but that the power of love is gonna open
up these doors and that these areas of
low access to these different types of
technologies they to build information
highways in those areas is really
important across the world if we can
learn how to do that together we will
leverage teamwork to make the dream work
this is such a pleasure thanks everyone
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time please give us a comment below let
us know what your thoughts were like the
video share it around with other people
let's get more people
understanding about the the gold teach
to learn to teach teach to learn
ecosystem here and that give us of
subscribe join the community join us on
patreon we need you to keep highlighting
things like this helping us support us
in this journey Mel thank you so much
excuse me thank you so much you are also
incredible thank you for your time
[Music]
all right guys
[Music]